[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
jim lewis and jim springer were
identical twins that were separated at
four weeks of age and then raised in
different families
after some searching in 1979 the twins
were finally reunited at the age of 39.
when they got to talking they were
astonished to discover how many ways
that they had lived identical lives for
example they both suffered from tension
headaches they were prone to nail biting
they smoked salem cigarettes they drove
the same type of chevrolet car and even
vacationed at the same beach in florida
both had similar jobs and security
jim lewis was a security guard while jim
springer had been a deputy sheriff
both married and divorced women named
linda
they both remarried women named betty
and they both had a childhood dog named
toy
they both had a proclivity for math and
woodworking but were terrible at
spelling
and they both named their sons james
allen the one spelled alan a little
differently
that's so bizarre it almost sounds like
they were predestined to live a certain
way
that's right
when you hear about these stories of
people that just lived lives that were
so similar to one another and you wonder
why was there somebody
coordinating events or putting this all
together now of course there's genetics
connected with that and certain
personality traits
but sometimes people ask the question
you know are there some predestinated to
be saved and are there some
predestinated to be lost and can we do
anything about our eternal destiny yeah
you hear a story like this and you might
think well we have no choice it's all
controlled by our genes
but this is one of those
it's a rare coincidence this is not
always the case with twins that are
separated sometimes their lives are
entirely different even though they're
identical twins
but there are people who think that you
know our our lives are all mapped out by
god and we really don't have a choice
but the bible tells us that
people's eternal destiny will largely
hinge on
how they respond to the sacrifice that
jesus has made a number of verses
illustrate this but even if you go to
one of the last verses in the bible
revelation 22
it says and this is a great invitation
that closes the book and the spirit and
the bride say come and let him who hears
say come and let him who thirsts come
and whoever desires let him come and
take the water of life freely this makes
it pretty clear that the invitation to
be saved is not only restricted for a
few people but it says whoever hears
whoever reads the words of his book
and i know there's a number of places
where the bible says god is not willing
that any should perish
well if some are going to perish that
obviously is not his will
that means not everything that happens
in this world is the will of god
you know some of our muslim friends
whatever happens they say well it must
be the will of allah
but no not the sin and misery in this
world is not god's will that's why in
the lord's prayer we say
thy will be done
why would we pray for something that's
already going to happen anyway
so we're praying for god's will because
a lot of things that happen are not
god's will
and
of course joshua made a statement that
explained we all have a choice that's
right one of the key verses here it's an
appeal to to receive the lord just
before the children of israel would
enter into the promised land joshua said
to the people if it seems evil to you
this is joshua 24 15
if it seems evil to you to serve the
lord choose for yourselves this day whom
you will serve
whether the gods that your father served
that were on the other side of the river
or the gods of the amorites in his land
you dwell but as for me and my house we
will serve the lord so there you see a
choice we need to choose who we wish to
serve now pastor dave there might be
some confusion because you read in
paul's letters sometimes he talks about
god predestinating
and people are wondering is that
referring to a person's eternal destiny
but the confusion is there it is true
that god predestinated the nation of
israel to be the nation that would be
the one through whom the messiah would
come right that was a choice god made it
didn't have anything to do with the
israelites being better than anyone else
but that's not referring to individual
choice or individual destiny it's
referring to the nation and god raises
nations up and god takes nations down
uh maybe in that sense you can you can
understand the predestination of god but
individually we have that freedom to to
choose right some people think for
instance judas since prophecy said judas
would betray jesus judas had no choice
no god knew what was going to happen but
ultimately it was judas that made these
series of choices that led to his
very bad choice his decision to betray
jesus now we've got a free offer i think
that helps explain this with all the
scriptures we do it's a popular book
folks want to learn more about the
subject it's called can a saved man
choose to be lost this is our free gift
to anyone who will call and ask all you
need to do is just call the number
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
can a saved man choose to be lost again
that's
800-835-6747 and i tell them you're
listening to bible answers live and you
like the free gift it's called can a
saved man choose to be lost another
number that you might want to write down
is our phone line here to the studio
with your bible question the number for
that is 800-463-7297
800-463-7297 we've got some phone lines
that are still open this is a good time
for you to pick up your phone and give
us a call we also pass that i want to
greet those who are listening on amazing
facts television we also folks have
tuned in on social media on the doug
batchelor facebook page on the amazing
facts facebook page and i believe you
also are live at the amazing facts
youtube
channel so many ways that you can
participate and of course those who are
listening on land-based radio stations
and also satellite radio so welcome to
the program that's right you can listen
you can watch and listen and we invite
either
but before we go to our questions we're
going to ask god for his guidance let's
have a word of prayer dear father once
again we are grateful for the
opportunity to be able to open up your
word and study and lord we do recognize
that this bible this book that you have
given us is a powerful book containing
truth and it's your book so we ask for
your spirit the holy spirit to guide us
as we study together be with those who
are listening watching wherever they
might be and we ask this in jesus name
amen amen
well we are ready to go to the phone
lines the first caller that we have is
sophia listening in tennessee
sophia welcome to the program
thank you
and your question
is the united states in the book of
daniel and if so where are the passages
thank you
all right good question
now you do find the united states
mentioned in the book of revelation is
the second beast you find in revelation
chapter 13. but pastor ross i guess
the um the events connected with the
united states would be
in the last
following the last beast that you find
in daniel well it would be in following
the iron and the clay
it's not specifically mentioned but it'd
probably be
you know following those ten toes maybe
it's the toenails just prior to the
stone that comes and starts the image it
seems that the focus of the book of
daniel deals more with kingdoms that of
course from daniel's time lead you all
the way up to the second coming of
christ but most of the kingdoms referred
to has to do with europe or influencing
the land of israel whereas we find an
expansion of that of course in the book
of revelation revelation 13 in
particular there is a beast power that
arises the second beast and that is the
united states in prophecy yeah by the
time you get to the book of revelation
the prophets seem to go into more detail
in fact it even happens and i know i've
heard you say this many times that
what's happening in the prophecies of
the bible is it's stating the truth then
as it goes on it expands
and you're getting the same truth from
different angles
daniel 2 you've got those five major
kingdoms being
babylon medo-persia greece rome and then
the divisions of the roman empire and
you also get that well it's in daniel 7
it's in daniel 8 it's in daniel 9 10 11.
and each succeeding vision seems to
expand and give more detail
now we do have a magazine at amazing
facts it's called the usm bible prophecy
this is one of our most popular sharing
magazines that we have
and we will make that available to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call for that is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the magazine it's
called the usn bible prophecy it's quite
an in-depth study pastor though but it
looks at these various prophecies and
it's really inspiring read it for
yourself and then give it to a friend
it's a very important topic amen all
right thank you for your call next
quarter that we have is diana listening
in texas
deanna welcome to the program
thank you pastors good evening
my question is
in the book of mark when jesus healed
the leper he asked him not to tell
anybody and he's done that a couple of
times and i just wanted to know why he
would do that
yeah and it's funny because in almost
every case he said don't tell anybody
and they did
you know if you've been blind or you've
been a leper and you've had all that
misery and then all of a sudden you're
healed it is hard to keep the good news
to yourself
i think one reason jesus did that is
because
there were already enemies that were
very jealous and uh looking for some
reason
to obstruct his ministry
and
he knew that when he did these
especially
um
powerful miracles
that as word about that spread
it just intensified the persecution and
the scrutiny and he wanted to help these
people but he did not want to see the
word limited he said now don't mention
that also tells you about the humility
of christ and it also reminds us that
it's hard to keep good news to yourself
so i would think that that would be the
main reason he was just trying to
prevent
too much resistance so early in his
ministry although the time does come
where jesus talks to his disciples and
he says then what you hear in secret you
blaze from the rooftops so it was clear
that there was going to be a time when
everything that jesus did was to be
loudly proclaimed and then by the time
he healed lazarus right by jerusalem it
was front page news absolutely yeah and
christ didn't hide that in any reason
well thanks for your call deanna we've
got
angela listening from illinois angela
welcome to the program
hi pastor doug and pastor ross off
i
wanted to understand in chapter 11
of um
daniel it talks about the king of the
north and south
so can you just tell me who's the king
of the north who was the king of the
north and south
well now just i'll let you know i'll do
my best
if you ask 10 different pastors what
they believe about daniel you know 10
and 11 and even into 12 you'll get 12
different answers
um it's it's a uh it's a very it's
probably the most um
complex and detailed prophecy in the
bible i can't think of one that maybe
some in ezekiel or zechariah but this is
pretty complex my belief is and mo i
think pastor ross would agree with me
the king of the north would be what we
call the papacy
and because it's the papacy as a as a
power a religious power is outlined in
both revelation 17 during the same time
period
and in the other chapters of daniel
the king of the south is where you're
going to find some
difference of belief some believe that
it's
atheism uh some believe it's kingdom of
turkey
some believe it's islam
now i am probably more inclined to
believe that the king of the south is
islam and i could be wrong but my reason
for that is you see these two great
powers that are at war
and the two biggest religions in the
world today are christianity and islam
and uh i can just see where that would
be the catalyst for a great battle that
would bring about the final events
so yep got to keep studying like i said
i'm not dogmatic about that
i think you're right pastor
you know if you look at the difference
between the king of the north and the
king of the south there is significance
geographically so you have rome which of
course you have pagan rome which gives
way to papal rome
because paper rome is still very much
active and powerful even today
and then there is a power or an entity
standing in opposition to papal rome
preventing paper rome from having
worldwide influence well
the muslim religions it does seem to fit
into that so i think there's something
there uh but also atheism could play
there's a number of of interesting
things some of what we read in daniel
chapter 11 is yet in the future
right so when these events begin to take
place i think it'll make a lot clearer
understanding a lot of chapter 11 is
historic and has already been fulfilled
but when you get down to the last few
verses or starting around 43 i believe
somewhere in there it's still referring
to events in the future so we'll have to
see see what happens
that's right jesus said when these
things come to pass then you will know
and so someone once said the prophecy is
best understood looking back
so we'll go oh yeah god was right on
yeah
all right thanks for your call angela
we've got uh aaron listening from new
york erin welcome to the program
hi pastors
hi thanks for calling
my question is
um in matthew chapter 4 verse 1 it says
that jesus was led by this holy spirit
into the willingness to fast and be
tempted by the devil
but in the model prayer in matthew
chapter six
jesus mentioned in chapter in uh verse
uh lead us not into temptation
what does he mean by that
yeah uh
when you say the lord's prayer in that
verse that we commonly say in english
and lead us not into temptation it
almost creates the word picture
that god is wanting to put a leash
around our necks and walk us off into
temptation we're begging him not to
but then you read in james god tempts no
man
and
god would never deliberately try to
entice us to evil god is not setting up
a sting operation through entrapment
um sometimes if we drive the lord away
we'll be left to our own devices and we
will be subject to the devil's
temptations
but
really the way the lord's prayer would
probably be more accurately stated is
lead us away from our naturally tendency
tendency to evil now when you read where
it tells about the temptation of christ
in the wilderness he was led of the
spirit well when jesus was baptized he
was filled with the holy spirit the
bible says he was anointed with the holy
spirit that's why he's called the christ
or the anointed
and he went into the wilderness to pray
about his mission so he's led by the
spirit into the wilderness
well why he's there he is severely
tempted of the devil not to go through
with his mission
but the the spirit was not saying okay
let's go get you tempted if we can the
spirit was really leading him into the
wilderness to pray about his mission
and there the devil tempted him
and he of course resisted and overcame
the devil so god allowed that no doubt
but it wasn't though the the spirit was
tempting him god would never tempt with
evil
you know we got a book past today called
tips for existing temptation it's got a
number of good bible uh scripture there
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call is 800 800-835-6747
that is our resource phone line you can
ask for the book it's called tips for
resisting temptation
now it's not a sin to be tempted and the
bible makes that clear
but when temptation comes how do we
overcome the bible calls us to be
overcomers we can be overcomers and
there's some wonderful promises in the
bible that we can claim so call and ask
for that book you will be blessed
next quarter that we have is let's see
we got doug listening in colorado doug
welcome to the playlist
well good evening pastors um evening my
question might seem a little unusual
there is a country song
that speaks of the day that christ was
born on earth and it talks about the
angels crying because they knew
what he
was what was before him
is there any biblical evidence to that i
know the only thing i've read in the
bible that i can think of about
angels emotions were sorrowful
but is there anything to that
you know it actually tells us that when
jesus was born that the angels met the
shepherds and said rejoice
we've got good news
and the angels were singing
and they said peace on earth joy
and so angels definitely have emotions
you know i believe angels are grieved
when we sin i'm sure angels were crying
when jesus was on the cross and i might
be missing something pastor ross but i
don't think there's any verse that says
angels were crying at his birth actually
sounds like it was the opposite
goodwill
seems like there was a great joy because
it was through the birth of christ that
salvation would come so you know i don't
know if the angels fully understood
everything that was going to happen i
mean i'm sure they understood that
christ's mission would involve sacrifice
and suffering but they like us witnessed
this great plan of redemption play out
for the salvation of mankind
and um i'm sure they would have
willingly come down to rescue jesus from
the cross
but they knew it was not part of god's
plan but i even think for the angels the
idea of the incarnation how god the son
could become a human
was both mysterious and a wondrous thing
for them and they beheld that and
thought wow what condescension the
humiliation of jesus that going from god
to being a creature
um i think that that left them in marvel
at his love
but they said boy this is good news for
man yeah so they couldn't wait for it to
announce that their king had come
all right next quarter that we have is
michael listening in uh california
michael welcome to the program
michael you're there rio vista
california
michael you're on
um
why did um
the um
nehemiah
wrote the ball of jerusalem
why did nehemiah build the walls around
jerusalem
is that
right yeah well because
uh during the time when the babylonians
they were enemies of israel
they had conquered israel and they
destroyed the wall so
when after the babylonian kingdom fell
the persian king let the jews go back to
jerusalem but the city walls were broken
down and they had no protection from
their enemies these cities they needed
walls so the citizen citizens could go
in
and be fortified and protected against
the enemies if there was a war
and they had no protection and of course
the temple was there all their
leadership was there and the capital
needed security and they they needed to
build up the walls and there was a
prophetic significance to them building
the wall because according to daniel
there was a time period that would begin
the prophetic time period begins with
the restoration and rebuilding not only
of the temple but of the city
yeah which required the walls and uh you
know that was 457 bc very significant
date in that time process that's right
good point thank you michael hope that
helps appreciate your question we've got
danny listening in arizona danny welcome
to the program
hey how you doing pastors doing
great awesome awesome well my question
comes from
uh colossians 2 16. so a friend of mine
came to me and said hey so guess what um
when i read this
verse he said um
that the sabbath no longer applies after
in the new testament i go how does it
not apply in the new testament well if
you read collagen so i'm going to read
it it says therefore denial anyone
well you just festival or new moon for a
sabbath day yeah
well look hey i'm well like what that
doesn't make sense how is that
yeah yeah
well first of all yeah i don't know what
version you're reading but if you look
in the king james or the new king james
most versions it says let no one judge
you in food or drink or regard to
festival or new moon or sabbaths
now the seventh day of the week sabbath
is completely unique and different from
the jewish
annual sabbaths that came
during the exodus and they were
connected with the temple and his
services
the sabbath at the end of every week is
a day of rest for mankind that's why
jesus said the sabbath was made for man
not for jews
that happened before adam and eve
ever sinned god made the sabbath it was
part of his perfect plan
when paul is talking here he's talking
about these ceremonial sabbaths they
were annual feasts and there were other
days they called sabbaths that had
nothing to do with the weekly day of
rest
so paul is addressing the ceremonial
laws that were nailed to the cross
it has nothing to do with blotting out
one of the ten commandments and by the
way why of all the ten commandments why
would god take the one commandment that
begins with the word remember and say
now that's the only one you're supposed
to forget
that wouldn't make any sense and of
course do people still need a weekly day
of gathering and worship and this is
what the sabbath was all about so yeah
colossians 2 talking about annual
sabbaths that's why it's plural there in
the original greek i think the very next
verse helps to explain that a little bit
it says which are a shadow of things to
come
so of course if you look at the
festivals you look at the new moon or
the monthly services or programs the
ceremonial sabbath it was always
pointing forward to christ and
redemption whereas the seventh-day
sabbath points back to creation right so
that verse helps to explain that they
were shadows the ceremonial sabbath
hope that helps now we have a book
they're called feast days and sabbaths
yes and we'll be happy to share you a
free copy of that to receive that just
call the number 800 835
and you can ask for the book feast days
and sabbaths and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks
800-835-6747
next quarter that we have is david
listening in california david welcome to
the program
yeah thank you pastor doug ross yeah the
question is about tithing
a little different spin here about
giving tides to churches
that
like have the sabbath on sunday believe
in
you know you die you go to heaven a lot
of pandemic had a lot of churches and
states come together
i just can't see you supporting the
church when so many of them are teaching
different things in the bible that i
don't think are correct yeah
well
you know i would say first and foremost
that when it comes to tithe we
if you're attending a church
then you would want to support that
church from which you are drawing
benefit
and uh
god outlines a plan in the scriptures
and by the way we'll send you a study
guide that has a number of scriptures on
tithing tithing is a biblical principle
not just for the old testament tithing
predated the time of moses
talk about jacob payne tithe and abraham
gave a tenth to melchizedek and
you know it's the only plan that god has
in the bible
for the ongoing support of ministry
you do need to
make sure you're belonging to a
bible-based church and or denomination
and so when you're supporting it with
your presence with your influence with
your gifts
you want to be supporting the
proclamation of truth
and so that's an important principle but
yeah we'll be happy to send that to you
or anyone that has questions and what
does the bible say about you know tithe
and offerings and and how does a new
testament christian respond to that the
number to call is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the amazing
facts study guide it's called in god we
trust and we'll be happy to send you
that lesson on what does the bible have
to say about money and how we to use our
money again it's 800-835-6747
as for the study guide in god we trust
uh next quarter that we have is uh while
i'm looking at the time pastor that we
probably don't have time to take
phillips call but philip if you'd stand
by we're going to take a break here in
about a minute and a half
um we'll definitely take your call when
we come back after the break and for our
friends who are listening don't go too
far we're going to be taking a break
here in a few minutes but you know
pastor doug just before the break
there's a number of exciting things
happening here at amazing facts and i
know we have folks who listen not only
in north america but even in central
america and south america and next month
you're going to be spending some time in
mexico city and i think you just got
back from a trip there i did just had a
wonderful time in the
big city of mexico city like 25 million
people there and actually in october
we're going to be there for
a couple of weeks doing meetings and of
course i don't speak spanish just a
little bit so we've got a good
translator going with us one of our
amazing facts evangelist and the city is
so big people can't actually go to
one location because the traffic is so
bad so we're doing the meetings five
days in one location five days in
another location kind of going east and
west across the city
and
it'll be streaming on the internet so
our friends can tell their friends we'll
give you more information later on how
you can link to those meetings in mexico
city
and be streaming that also we have the
best half of the program still coming if
you want to call in with your bible
questions
simply call 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
and you can not only listen on the radio
but we are streaming on the internet
these programs are going out on the
amazing facts facebook page the doug
batchelor facebook page the youtube page
and amazing facts television and um
we've got some announcements we'll share
with you soon about how the amazing
facts bible answers live program is
going to be going forth onto some other
major networks we're very excited about
but we're just taking a break right here
going to get a drink of water come back
to answer more of your bible questions
so don't go anywhere
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about
top scholars and theologians from around
the country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
visit itunes or afbookstore.com
[Music]
you always wanted to be a bible expert
but never knew where to start
are you searching for answers that will
bring you joy peace and fulfillment
then you'll love the amazing facts
historicals of prophecy bible study
experience now available in 18 languages
featuring 24 easy-to-read lessons the
historicals are packed with scripture
and step-by-step guidance that will give
you absolute confidence about what the
bible actually says about the second
coming the rapture the antichrist and
the mark of the beast
you'll also get the truth about hell and
the afterlife and practical insight
about grace salvation and how to truly
live like jesus
even better it's absolutely free at
storicals.com
so don't miss out get started on your
bible study adventure today at
storacles.com
[Music]
written by the hand of god
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
get pastor doug batchelor's 12-part
sermon series on the 10 commandments by
calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's
welcome back 800-463-7297 friends to
bible answers live and we're going to be
going back to the phones in just a
moment if you've tuned in along the way
this is a live international interactive
bible study and you're invited to call
in with your bible questions the phone
number if you're calling north america
800 god says that's 800-463-7297
and my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and we've got a number of
folks waiting on the phone so we're
going to go to philip who's listening in
texas philip welcome to bible answers
live
hey good evening pastors evening and my
question is on job 42 7 the lord tells
job's friends that they have not spoken
of me what is right as my servant job
has now i know they had a mistaken idea
that job must have sinned to cause all
the calamity on him is that what god's
talking about or was there something
else
they said that was not right about god
well most of what job's friends said was
absolutely true in a general sense they
were talking about the ways that god
judges the wicked
and how it's so much better to be
righteous
but they were wrong about job job's
particular sufferings were
a unique experience you know sometimes
god sends the reign on the just and the
unjust in other words good and bad
people experience trials
bad people sometimes experience
blessings and this is what job is saying
in his response
is that he's seen wicked people look
like they're prospering
and he's seeing righteous people look
like they're suffering his friends are
saying no god
you know god blesses the righteous and
he punishes the wicked and this is sort
of the dialogue that goes on through the
book so
what job's friend said was wrong was
accusing job
of guilt they are saying job no way
would anyone go through all of the
mishap that you've experienced unless
you had done something to provoke god
and job said no
i've been faithful
and
in the end his god says you know your
friends have not spoken what was right
they were sort of prejudging job
and job's like a type of christ
you know jesus went through all this
suffering not because of his sin but for
our sake
and if you were to judge christ just
based on suffering you'd say he must be
a great sinner because look at all the
terrible things that happened you know
he's nailed to the cross and he's
deserted by his disciples they even said
that to why he was on the cross right
yeah they said if you know if god's with
you then why is this happening right
all right good question phillip thank
you uh joel is listening in north
carolina joel welcome to the program
hi pastors
hi thanks for calling i have
i have a question about the remnant um
i'm a status keeper and
i've been told and taught that
where the revenant church but
as i read the bible i was wondering
is the remnant that jesus is coming back
for it's
people it's
not a denomination right correct
now yeah
it does but let me clarify just so that
we don't misunderstand
in the old testament joel would you
agree
that god had a particular people a
nation he was working through
namely that would be israel
does that make sense yeah
but not every israelite was saved
and not every gentile was lost
you still with me
yeah so in the last days is god working
through a particular movement yes
does that mean everybody that is a
member of that movement is saved no
and does that mean everybody who is not
is lost no
uh you know the lord has his people
and you know that's why jesus said many
will come from the east and the west and
sit down in the kingdom with abraham
isaac and jacob
but you know god does work through
nations i think god especially rose up
the united states to be sort of a beach
head for great international missions
you know when it was established that
doesn't mean every american is a
christian or every american is saved but
god certainly worked through the nation
just as god raised up israel
for a particular purpose they were to be
you know even jesus said salvation is of
the jews that didn't mean every jew was
saved
and likewise paul says to israel were
committed the oracles of god
so we do have a book actually that talks
now do we have a book that talks about
the remnant for say pastor we've got one
called the bride of christ yeah there's
about uh how god is working through his
people and the verse for that passage
revelation chapter 12 verse 17 it says
in the dragon satan was enraged with the
woman the church
and he went to make war with the remnant
or the rest of offspring those who keep
the commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus so here you have
god's people in the last days they keep
his commandments they have the testimony
of jesus
and the dragon satan is enraged with
them well the study guide the bride of
christ there's a lot more information
about revelation and about god's people
in the last days
and
if you'd like to receive that just call
and ask the number to call is 800-835
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called the bride of christ and we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks
all right
who's next then we've got ryan and ryan
is listening in tennessee ryan welcome
to the program
hey good evening sure hi i was putting
my seven-year-old daughter to bed
tonight and she reminded me about the
show
um this evening so she decided to watch
the show tonight stay up late and i
thought i'd call him with a question
it's about revelation 21 1
it says i saw a new heaven and a new
earth because the first heaven and earth
had disappeared and the sea was gone
i'm curious uh is that a specific sea
that's being referenced there or is that
the entire like all the oceans on the
earth will they be gone well you know
when you think about an ocean it's
interesting we've got the great great
lakes
and uh we have great lakes here in north
america that are bigger than the sea of
galilee well they call the sea of
galilee a sea
and it's full of fresh water and then
you've got one of the great lakes i
think it's superior is salt water i
forget which one
and it's salt water
so the terms are sort of interchangeable
i think god is saying in the new earth
the typical sea that we have now is not
going to hurt people's eyes it's not
going to be salty and undrinkable
and there's not going to be a large vast
expanse of water that will separate
people there will definitely be bodies
of water because it says there's a river
that is flowing from the throne of god
so if you've got a river rivers flow
into
lakes
or seas
so i just think we're not going to have
that big
um
briny salty sea separating the people of
the world
okay all right hey thanks good question
ryan
all right next caller that we have is
brittany listening in california uh
brittany welcome to the program
hey yeah on your question tonight
yeah my question is what does the bible
say about college degrees
what does the bible say about college
degrees
uh well i i think
i think it tells us that um
they asked jesus
or they asked others how does jesus know
all these things having
not learned and i think that what the
phrase they
they're using there is like saying he
doesn't seem to have any formal
education
now god can work with people that may
not have formal education but formal
education is very valuable i don't think
there's a scripture
solomon i've done a lot of graduations
where i talk about solomon's statement
on wisdom get wisdom with your getting
get understanding so the bible is very
clear he wants us to use our minds and
to learn all we can because you'll be
more productive
but i don't know if you find the word
college degree
because the bible gives you the
principle that whatever you find to do
do it with all your might in other words
do the best job you can and pastor doug
if you sick and you're going to go see a
doctor or a nurse you sure hope they
they've done some education they know
what they're doing so i think there's
nothing wrong for christians to learn
and to be the best that they can be in
whatever area god is leading them in
yeah you know what you think about the
story of daniel shadrach meshach and
abednego they went through intensive
training for three and a half years
about
uh so that they could stand in the
king's palace and because of their
education and they were able to speak uh
the language of the chaldeans as well as
aramaic
and hebrew they were able to do a lot
more and god was able to use them
so
even though it was not the it was not a
hebrew education they had both actually
didn't they
it the lord was able to use them because
they had that additional wisdom so
college is good learning is good pick a
good college
that's right
not everything you learn in college is
good that's right
all right next quarter that we have is
tim listening in washington tim welcome
to the program
yeah yeah this is uh the truck driver
that went and saw you in uh vegas that
time and that was
it
was the best experience i've ever had
but uh
so
one of my other truck driving friends i
i always make sure that this truck shuts
down
friday night and doesn't move till
saturday night to the earliest the best
i can
so i was explaining to him about
the importance of taking the sabbath and
stuff like that and he doesn't
he he says that
um
it doesn't like it well the time that we
live and now he can't do that but also
so my question is
i also went into
the three angels message about
um
hey tim let me ask you a question if i
could and by the way thanks again for
coming to the meetings there in vegas is
your friend a christian
he says that he is but he does not go to
church
well you know it seems to me that if
you're going to work on a person there
are varying
degrees of commitment
and you know the first thing a person
would want i want to go to a person and
talk to him about
the sabbath if they've not yet made a
complete surrender to jesus you know
the first and foremost is that a person
accepts christ and the sacrifice and you
want to focus on those things
and then as they make their commitment
to jesus they're going to say you know i
want to obey him jesus said if you love
me keep my commandments
and then as they learn those things
they're wanting to do what pleases the
lord at that point so it's sort of
progressive in that way
that is why i was talking to him about
the sabbath is because we were you know
he says yes you're supposed to keep what
is written down on the stones that i
tell them all the sabbath commandment is
but my question was so he believes
that you can have the mark of the beast
but still go to heaven
okay
let's talk about that
you know if there's one thing that's
exceedingly clear in the bible is if you
read
in revelation chapter 13
it says for instance verse nine so in
revelation 14 verse nine
then the third angel followed them with
a loud voice if anyone worships the
beast in his image and receives his mark
on his forehead or in his hand he
himself shall also drink of the wine of
the wrath of god which is poured out
full strength into the cup of his
indignation
and he will be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lamb
it makes it pretty clear
that the wicked
those that receive the mark of the beast
receive the fate of the wicked it's
completely out of god's will they're
kind of making themselves enemies of god
and they received some of the most
severe judgments mentioned in scripture
you know we do have a study guide
talking about the three angels message
and it's called messages from space
angel messages from space and one of
those messages is talking about the mark
of the beast so we'll be happy to send
that to anyone wanting to learn more
about the subject the number to call is
800-835-6747
you can ask for the amazing facts study
guide called angel messages from space
and you will be blessed by reading that
thanks tim and we got will listening in
canada will welcome to bible answers
live
hello
yes
i will yeah
my question is in genesis chapter 1
verse 28.
i would like to know does it still apply
to us today
people living in the end time
especially
be fruitful and multiply
and replenish the earth
that is to apply to us i believe that we
are living
uh really at the end end of time yeah
you know you need to mix this verse well
first of all keep in mind that when god
first tells adam and eve to be fruitful
multiply and fill the earth the word
replenishes also the word phil
he wanted to populate the world with the
the humans that he made in his image
but clearly you know by the time you get
to the flood man had become so wicked
that god depopulated the earth
and then after noah and his family were
saved he again tells him be fruitful and
fill the earth well the earth is getting
pretty full and then jesus tells us in
matthew 24
speaking of this great time of trouble
he says woe to those who are with child
and nursing in those days
on the way to the cross he talked to the
women that were weeping for him and said
don't weep for me weep for yourself
because the days are coming where you
where you're going to say blessed are
the wombs that did not bear and the
breasts that did not nurse and
because
and even paul said during this great
roman persecution he said it might be
better not to marry
because you get married and in the
progression you bring children into a
world where christians were severely
persecuted
so
i think you need to take a lot of things
into account and
i would
far be it for me to tell a couple
you know you shouldn't get married or
shouldn't have children that's something
every individual needs to pray about but
there will come a time in history where
it's going to be probably prudent not to
have a lot of children
all right thanks you call well we've got
theo listening in toronto theo welcome
to the program
hello hi
hi um
my question is um what does the
what should you do to not dwell
on certain continuous problems that
occur
so um a couple of months ago i graduated
and
i was playing basketball and i tore my
meniscus and acl so i just wanted to
know
what
should one do to not
focus on the past and how to navigate
continuous trials
yeah well first of all uh i will pray
that uh your your knee heals up i know
people that have had that problem and
and they did heal it hopefully you're
younger and
and uh it'll get better
but um
you know whenever you go through a trial
uh know that god for a believer god can
use every hardship and every trial
in a redemptive way and he can turn it
for good i mean you might find well
because you've torn your knee
but now you're going to take some time
and you're going to start studying and
learn a new language that will bless you
the rest of your life and you'll look
back and say wow i was glad i hurt my
knee i never would have learned that new
language i'm just making that up but
god can work things
for good
and so
we do have
you know some encouraging things online
that talk about how to
how to endure trials i have a new book
i've written
that talks about how to live in peace in
a world full of worry
and um
you know there's a lot of trials in the
world and people are wanting to know how
can i have peace in spite of my trials
and that's kind of what you're asking
right now
and i don't think pastor we have that
book available no well it's at the
amazing facts bookstore it is it's not
expensive but you'd have to buy that one
right yeah absolutely
all right next quarter that we have is
um susie listening from colorado susie
welcome to the program
hi thanks for taking my call uh before i
ask you my question i just want to say
because of you
and many prayers and the working of the
holy spirit my son and grandson were
baptized amen
that's incredible i appreciate your
program a double blessing my question
yes it is uh my question is isaiah 14
13.
satan is saying i want to sit on the
mountain of the meeting in the sides of
the north and i don't understand any of
that
yeah well and this is a passage in
isaiah and for our friends that are uh
listening
uh and you said isaiah 14 15
which verse
for isaiah 14 13. oh 13 all right let me
read this for our friends this is a
a prophecy in the bible where isaiah he
starts out talking about a king
and then he transitions to the power the
evil power behind the king which is the
devil
for you said in your heart i will ascend
into heaven i will exalt my throne above
the stars of god i'll also sit on the
mount of the congregation on the farther
sides of the north uh people in the
ancient world and even people today
you say you're in australia they call it
down under
you look at the globe and you figure
north is top or up
and even the ancients used to look
towards the north star
and
it was considered the heights of the
heavens
and so when
the devil is saying he wanted to sit in
the farthest parts of the north he's
basically saying he wanted to be
on the top of the pile he wanted the
highest position
and you keep reading it says i'll exalt
my throne above the stars of god i will
sit on the mount of the congregation on
the farthest sides of the north i will
ascend above the heights of the clouds i
will be like the most high but you will
be brought down to shield the lowest
depths of the pit this is the devil
wanting the position of god the highest
position
and the farther sides of the north north
was sort of an ancient way of saying
that
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about um the origin of sin it's
called did god create a devil and
actually gets into this very passage in
isaiah chapter 14. we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747
and you can ask the study guide did god
create a devil and a look at these
different old testament passages also
new testament that talks about our
adversary the devil and where he came
from it's an informative study
thank you for your call um susie we've
got
joshua listening in
indiana joshua welcome to the program
hello uh thank you pastors uh
uh good evening to you evening
well my question is um
who is lilith is she a real
person from the bible or he a myth and
while we're on that how do we know
which stories that are connected to like
the bible and the
aura and how do we know if they're
mythological or real
well first of all the the books of moses
have been
unanimously believed by
jews and christians to be a sacred
history that is accurate
lilith is from a tradition
that is not found in in any um
jewish history until much later i think
it was following the babylonian
captivity and the a lot of myths drew
out and
i think some of the apocryphal books
that you might find for instance in the
catholic bible these don't these are
sort of manufactured
but they're nowhere near the level of
the the torah the pentateuch the books
of moses
a little for our friends that are
listening there's a legend that you know
adam and eve had our adam had a first
wife before eve and something went south
with her her name was lilith and then
later eve came along
and you know that that's a that is a
myth
don't let
don't let the myths
don't let the broken glass distract you
from the diamond there's no different i
mean there's no comparison i should say
between
the scriptures that you would find in
the bible that have stood the test of
time and some of these traditions and
fables the bible is the best-selling
book in history
not the legends of lilith
you know many of the stories that you
read about in the bible are referenced
by other writers in the bible and even
jesus himself for example jonah jesus
said as jonah was right a whale three
days and three nights so jesus doesn't
mention lilith no he doesn't
but he doesn't either peter james john
or the other bible authors isaiah so you
won't find any of them referencing that
you do find ezekiel talking about job he
talks about noah talks about daniel and
so they were real characters so they
cross reference as you say the others
okay good question next quarter that we
have is um
we've got scott listening in florida
scott welcome to the program
hey are you doing pastors good
morning
i know you don't have much time so i'm
going to get right to it uh revelation
and 10
because you have kept my word
and patience of endurance
i will keep you from the hour
of trial
which is coming to
the whole world
i'm having a lot of trouble
when i'm talking to people about the
pre-tribulation
yeah and they keep on bringing this
verse up
saying well yeah yeah this is what do
you guys what you have to say about this
i said well it's not going to be a
secret rapture it's going to be
at the same time he's just going to
protect
us the church of philadelphia which
without getting into the
two churches and the candlesticks and
two witnesses and all that
well yeah the seven churches
uh well i'm sorry go ahead let me let
you finish
no i just how can i kind of snub that
without getting into you know this big
theological speech about you know and
getting into the 44 000 and the two
witnesses right
i just i just want a quicker answer i
guess
well the promise that god makes to the
church of philadelphia is talking about
the experience of the church in a
certain age of history it is not the
last age the last age is when you get to
the church of laodicea
and the idea that god is going to keep
us from the hour of temptation god does
keep his people through trial and
temptation
god kept israel through the seven last
through the ten plagues that fell on the
egyptians
they were in egypt during the plagues
but he kept them he preserved them so
the idea that you can use this verse to
say that god is going to rapture the
church out of the world because he loves
us too much to allow us to go through
trial that's inconsistent with
everything else in the bible
paul said in the book of acts
that all that live godly in christ jesus
will suffer persecution actually that's
in timothy paul said
it is through much tribulation we enter
the kingdom of god
and
joseph was redeemed through tribulation
you find job being saved through
tribulation god preserved them through
the tribulation but they experienced
some trials
and so god preserving this church does
not mean
that
all the godly will suffer trials all
that live ungodly will suffer trials
so to use this verse to say that this is
evidence that god is going to
rapture the church out of the world
before the time of trouble jesus said he
that endures to the end the same will be
saved endures what well you we're going
to be here and there'll be something to
endure but he preserves his people psalm
91 says
no plague will come now you're dwelling
you'll look to your right in your left
and only with your eyes will you see the
destruction of the wicked you're there
but he's preserving you
so the seven last plagues very similar
to the plagues that fell on egypt
israel was in egypt during the plagues
and he preserved them we will be
preserved during this time of trouble
don't fear it
but it doesn't mean we're raptured out
of the world
and i think specifically you mentioned
that pastor doug the message here is to
the church of philadelphia yeah there
are seven divisions seven churches that
we find in revelation chapter two and
three and they represent seven time
periods of the christian era it's very
clear there's a number of theologians
and bible scholars that recognize this
and the church of philadelphia that time
period ends around 1844. yeah well of
course you know we've been here since
then more than 150 years whatever it's
been it's really to the seventh church
the church of laodicea
that we actually have the church at the
time of the plagues and the second
coming of christ
exactly so
hopefully that makes sense and
it explains you know we do have a book
that talks about
the rapture and the tribulation scott
and we'll be happy to send you a free
copy it's called anything but secret and
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the book
called anything but secret there is a
rapture it is not a secret
he's coming like a thief but the heavens
will pass away with a great noise and
elements will melt with fervent heat hey
listening friends it's been a delight
this is uh one of the fastest hours in
the week we're coming back in a few
minutes with rapid fire bible questions
signing off with our satellite listeners
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back again for our
uh internet questions and thank you for
sending in your emails and your
questions pastor we've got a number of
great questions that's come in and we're
going to see how many we can get to in
the next two minutes or so so here's
question number one uh does the bible
say that the wicked will burn up at
different lengths of time depending upon
their wickedness
it doesn't word it that way but jesus is
pretty clear he said a he that knew his
master's will and did not do it will be
beaten with many stripes of course we're
not going to be whipped in heaven it's
talking about suffering
and he that did not know his masters
well and did not do it will be beaten
with few stripes and then of course the
bible tells us every man is judged
according to his works and they're
rewarded according to their works and so
if there are varying works there are
obviously varying degrees of reward and
punishment so
i think the teaching is certainly there
in the bible
okay next question we have this is from
mary and she's asking about
clarification on paying tithe on social
security
do you pay on the gross amount or what
do you do if you're not working
all right so when you have social
security um if if when you um are
receiving your paycheck and something's
being taken out for social security if
you are paying on your gross income
during that those working years
you are paying tithe in advance really
on the social security so when you get
your check in retirement you say i
already paid tithe on that
now if you're deducting your social
security
during those working years and saying
i'm not paying tithe on that income
because it was deducted well then when
you get it later you should probably pay
on it
and if you want to play it safe try not
give the lord and you can't do it
friends
open the windows of heaven and bless you
another question we have uh emily's
asking is there a difference between
heaven paradise the new jerusalem are
they all the same place or do people go
to different places
well they're really all the same place
when we think about heaven
we think about the dwelling place of god
it sometimes is called the paradise of
god paradise is speaking more about the
garden of eden in the city of god
sometimes we might say i'm going to
heaven that's talking about the whole
realm of the redeemed which would be
everything up there
and the new jerusalem is going to be the
capital of the uh the world made new
um
you read about in revelation 21 and
revelation 22.
all right maybe one more quick question
pastor deck how do you love somebody who
is unrepentant and have done terrible
things
well hopefully you can ask for the
spirit to help you do it because
uh
while i was yet a sinner christ
loved me and i was unrepentant for a
good part of my life and he still loved
me and forgave me ask for his spirit to
do the same
god bless friends we'll study again next
week
[Music]
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your bible questions
[Music]